She is a symbol for freedom and one of the most recognized figures in the United States.
Located in New York Harbor, the Statue of Liberty is a depiction of the Roman goddess of freedom.
Dedicated in a large ceremony on October 28, 1886,...
...the statue's official name is "Liberty Enlightening the World."
Originally a gift from the citizens of France, she was designed by French sculptor Frederic Bartholdi.
However, only her right hand and torch were finished by 1876...
...and both were displayed at the American Centennial Exhibition.
Lady Liberty, as she is often called, is represented wrapped in robes.
In her right hand, she carries a torch meant to symbolize the light of reason.
Her left hand is carrying a book of laws...
...that is marked with the date the Declaration of Independence was signed.
From the base of the statue to the top of the torch, she measures 151 feet in height.
Built on an iron support structure, the Statue of Liberty's skin is made of copper.
Originally the color of copper, by 1900 the statue's exterior had begun to change color...
...and today she is the pale green color we know and love.
The statue's armature was designed by the same man...
...who designed France's Eiffel Tower, Alexandre Gustave Eiffel.
A joint effort of the French, Americans and countless hard workers,...
...the statue was to be built in France and shipped by boat to America.
She was presented to the Americans on Independence Day in 1884.
Tourists were originally open to travel up to Lady Liberty's crown to view the harbor below,...
...as well as making a narrow climb up to the torch.
However, the torch has been closed to visitors since the First World War.
After 2001's terrorist attacks in New York City, the Statue of Liberty and Liberty Island...
...were closed to tourists because of safety concerns.
Finally in 2009, the statue herself was reopened to the public.
Lady Liberty has witnessed well over a century's worth of history...
...and has come to embody the American ideal of freedom.